when you're growing up in new jersey was
your dream always to be a stand-up
comedian oh that was like my worst
nightmare what did you want to be i
think i just wanted like people to hear
what i had to say like i thought my
opinion was very valuable at a very
young age and because i'm the youngest
of six you just have to scream and yell
to get heard so that was definitely you
know a part of the were you a loud mouth
yeah and you would mouth off about
everything did you ever go up on a stage
and do stand up for a career
yeah was that your start yeah that's how
i started yeah and you'd go up and you
do your thing and you talk were you good
at it um i got good at it i mean yeah
you know in the beginning i had an
easier time i think if it had been more
difficult in the beginning i would have
probably given up more easily but i had
an easy time and then i went through the
rough patch like you know a year into it
where i would bomb all the time you mean
the first time you got up you were good
at it well i mean you know i had like 15
friends in the audience too so where did
you do that where did you go the first
time on melrose and then the laugh
factory
was it like oh my god i got to go do
this i better go take 50 drinks and get
up on that stage how old were you i had
to have like eight more degrees 20. you
were 20 years old and you walked up on a
stage for the first time did you have
stuff written down that you were going
to talk about yeah and you were really
well thought out about this and who
inspired all of this in you was there
some some person or some comedian that
you looked up to no i no i didn't want
to do stand up it was just kind of like
the my
what else to do yeah i was auditioning
and i was reading these people's lines
you know you go on auditions and
everyone's skinnier and prettier and i'm
like i'm jewish and i like i'm never
gonna be like like a supermodel type
girl and i just didn't even have any
interest in that i just thought i wanted
something where i could express my my
opinions and my point of view
without anyone kind of editing me and
and what do you mean you were
auditioning you were going out and
trying to what get on tv shows yeah like
no no like to to be an actress you had
to go and i was a terrible auditioner i
mean i couldn't even i mean that that
situation was way more uncomfortable
than going on stage where you could just
do what you wanted and then if you don't
get laughs you act like that was on
purpose did you begin to lose faith in
yourself because you'd go out and
audition for tv shows or commercials or
whatever the hell and did you begin to
say you know maybe i'm not a performer
yeah all the time i was like oh my god
what if because i was waiting tables for
six or seven years and where at oh my
god everywhere there's a place called
roasty shy of venice everywhere in l.a
and i got fired from every job i ever
had why because you didn't listen to
authority because i would go off on
people like if i didn't like like if so
my customers my customers and my
managers right like the manager like my
manager was this coke head you know and
he and he was just running and it was
like this lunch in place it wasn't even
appropriate to be doing cocaine at that
time
they'd be running around you know he's
like this italian guy was like you know
he's clearly jacked
yeah and i just went off on him i was
like can you just wait and do coke to
when it gets dark out like i can't tell
your boss went to do coke a regular
person right or i would go off on people
if they left me crappy tips i'd be like
you're an [ __ ] and you know like you
know you'd have big parties and people
don't understand this in in anywhere in
tipping and this is why i'm very
sensitive to it because i tip like 500
when i go out because i don't know what
it's like right and you'd go
you know i had a table of these guys and
you always know it's bad when they start
out like we're going to take care of you
we got you tonight don't worry about us
i'm like oh [ __ ] you're getting you're
getting maybe 20 if you're lucky there's
not gonna be anything over right so
and so we had these guys and and and i
was at this restaurant venice in in
venice california and he said
and this guy said that and you know it's
like an 800 bill it ended up being like
a bar tab i worked in the bar and it was
a bar it was really nice restaurant bar
and so i and you know you have to pay
taxes on that especially when they pay
with a credit card you have to pay
people don't know that the waitress has
to pay like eight percent of that so if
you're not even tipping me eight percent
i'm basically paying for you to go out
to dinner wow i didn't know that yes so
you have to pay a portion of your sales
that are not in cash right so the guys
you know they they he got money i saw
him collecting money from his whole
group and then you know on 800 he took
me like ten dollars wow and i went right
up to him in front of everyone and i was
like and his last name was some jewish
thing and i was like listen it's jews
like you
that could choose like me a bad name and
i said just so you all know he took me
ten dollars took your money took me took
me ten dollars on 800 and probably
pocketed the rest so have a great night
and congratulations on your friend and
you got fired for that
yeah i guess so but but yet you have you
have a good point in fact i've gone to
dinner with friends
who i look over and i see what they're
tipping and i go i would rather just pay
the bill so i can give the waiter a
decent tip absolutely i don't trust some
of the people that i dine with to do the
right thing by tipping so people are
always like chelsea you have to stop
paying and i'm like i'd rather settle
this and i don't like people talking
about spending money like paying like oh
i'll get this you get that it's like
just somewhere okay it's just somebody
i'm not splitting it i'm not eight okay
we don't need to split this